hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
september what is it the sixth
i don't know i'm on the road i have no
idea hang on a second what the hell's
today's date do i even have that on my
thing there it is september 6th
oh jesus here we go and guess what
it's football season everybody isn't
that fantastic
isn't that something that you really
enjoy
maybe you don't
maybe you're one of those people with
this with the with the telescopes
you know
and you don't know you don't know how to
talk at a party and everybody's sitting
there
and you're just waiting for someone in
the backyard to look up and be like oh
look at that shiny one what what's that
one
and someone else oh i think that's the
uh that's the north star you know the
north side is actually the shortest one
you guys used to sail back in the day
that's with their huge navigation and
then you finally get the pipe in
actually that's not the north star
that's jupiter and if you look right to
the right of it that's saturn every
97 000 months
their orbits are close enough that
they're right next to each other really
is that true yes it is okay i'm still
gonna [ __ ] the guy that thought that was
the north star but thanks for the
information
maybe you're one of those people but if
you're not
if you're not and you're into uh
football
i had one of the i had one of the best
[ __ ] times
i've had watching a foot watching
college football
in a long time i was at the hot rock
cafe
that used to be the trump taj mahal
and somehow that [ __ ] thing went out
of business i just really don't
understand how a casino can go out of
business unless the skim's getting out
of control
you know i've watched casino a couple
times i feel like that makes me an
expert right people can go on webmd and
[ __ ] you know
analyze themselves and decide you know
uh [ __ ] what alligator plaque pill
they're going to take i don't know maybe
i could [ __ ]
maybe i know some things
[Laughter]
anyway i love people who do it dude i
went on web and you know my neck was
stiff right
so last night i'm on webm webmd and it
turns out i think i have this very rare
disease from south america even though
i've never been there but you know uh
you know people fly in on the airports
all the time why don't you just go to a
doctor
you know what i mean
if you [ __ ]
my stove isn't working
all right call a repairman that fix the
stoves you know dude i i don't like that
i think that's just a little too simple
it's too easy
something about it feels real fishy
i don't like it you know like you like
whenever you used to watch law and order
and they make a rest in the first 10
minutes
as a fan of the show and anybody who
understands how tv's made they arrest
somebody in the first 10 minutes you go
like there's no way this [ __ ] person
did it they got 50 minutes to go here
what am i going to do is sit around and
watch them [ __ ] eat donuts waiting
for the next person to uh
get sexually assaulted what a [ __ ]
idea for a show right
special victims units
you know i think people really want to
watch rape victims every [ __ ] week
why would you want to watch that
never that's like a joke i had uh
a while back when uh that documentary
on michael jackson came out
his alleged victims people like did you
see it
did you see it i was like no
why would i want to watch
uh alleged pedophilia testimony
as my entertainment for that night
let's make some popcorn
and watch adults cry about what happened
to them as children
i don't want to see that [ __ ]
as entertainment i could see if i'm on
if i have [ __ ] jury duty
and i gotta sit there
he
at that [ __ ] trial right
um
so anyway i was at the uh
yeah i read up a little bit on the whole
trump taj mahal thing the thing fell
into such disarray at one point
trump sued and says take my [ __ ] name
off that thing
um
it was the amazing thing about that guy
relax liberals one of the most amazing
things about that guy is he became
a celebrity businessman
who's a businessman
that became a celebrity became such a
[ __ ] celebrity that people would ask
to license his name and they would slap
it on [ __ ]
you know it's like all those trump
hotels everybody acts like he's [ __ ]
in there it's like they're just
licensing his name all right the guy
had he was too busy doing a tv show
was that the apprentice was that what it
was called
the apprentice the uh the oppressor the
[ __ ] the ceo whatever the [ __ ] that
show was called they should bring that
back by the way
you know
make the whole country like him again
because everybody loved him when he was
on that show and he do that little snake
thing you fired
guess what you're fired because of that
you didn't you didn't do this that the
other thing with this company that we
all know doesn't really exist so because
of that you're fired
you know can anybody explain me why
there wasn't enough syrup for those
pancakes at the luau that you guys had
for that company that doesn't exist well
actually i i think it was it was dr
dre's responsibility
actually it wasn't my responsibility it
was cindy lopez you know what this is a
double firing dr dre
cindy lapa you're both fired
it's the stupidest [ __ ] ever but it was
fun to watch
uh i should have said dr dre the guy's
worth a billion dollars uh well he was i
don't know if he's going through a
[ __ ] divorce now god knows she's
going to get half of it
i supported him
i said you could do it
do those [ __ ] headphones yeah
that's worth 500 million isn't it
i love when you know there's a high
[ __ ] level divorce
right
a high-level divorce and uh there's all
this money involved
then like
the woman who didn't do [ __ ] starts to
like label everything that she did is
like like a position in a company
you know i managed the household
i was the ceo of breakfast
i oversaw the pool area
[Music]
that's how you did
kind of sounds to me like you laid
around in your pajamas you know and to
be fair i saw kelly clarkson
he's going through a divorce oh man that
thing just reeked
of under his elmig an artist marries her
manager
it's that piece of [ __ ] manager there
why'd you marry her what because your 15
of her [ __ ] road gigs wasn't enough
for you you wanted a hundred percent
and then if [ __ ] goes bad you get 50
guys getting guys going to get 200 grand
a month
a man
he's gonna get 200 grand a month from a
woman
get a job you [ __ ] bum
that's [ __ ] ridiculous
can you even carry a tune did you carry
your ass out the [ __ ] front door
there weren't a living
um
so anyway i was in uh atlantic city
right
a c
a
to the [ __ ] sea as the kids do
not say i fly into philly which is the
most disrespected [ __ ] major city
okay we're not gonna say it's an a level
city all right if we're gonna go with
like as far as size
skyline
and population
all right you got to go new york city's
number one
just because all the media's there
all right
because chicago is right there with them
my
kind of tune chicago is
the wrigley building chicago whiz
[ __ ] seven feet deep pizza for
whatever reason they never heard of
[ __ ] lasagna
um
and then i would say maybe los angeles
right
just as far as like i'm sure like
atlanta has more people or maybe houston
or something like that
but if you uh
maybe i should look that up you know
just cause hollywood's there right
and all you red state people goddamn
[ __ ] hollywood they're out there
drinking baby blood pedophilia all up in
the hills saying all your crazy witch
[ __ ]
why because you guys are out in the
woods with the sheet on your [ __ ]
head
you know
still hating black people see do you
like that that i acted like you're all
in the [ __ ] clan well stop acting
like we're all [ __ ] babies in
hollywood it's not all of us it's just a
couple of bad eggs
i don't know if that's [ __ ] wrong um
yeah
come on man we're the ones who make all
your [ __ ] movies
all your tv
right
oh my nose oh my nose marsha brady that
was us
all right give me back my son once again
that was us
all those wonderful movies all came from
there what do we do we always say a
couple of liberal things
on the twitter there and you're ready to
walk away from us
hee haw that was us
i didn't know if that was us all right
okay here we go uh
biggest
cities
in the u.s
what do we got here
now why did jacksonville come up first i
really
do not know how somebody a picture of
jacksonville came up first
it's the power of tim tebow
um all right new york city
los angeles chicago bam i flipped it i
should have said
i should have said los angeles second
then houston look at me crushing
it here's one you never would guess
phoenix arizona
because they're all spread out you'd
have no idea and then coming in at
number six
is philadelphia pennsylvania now god
damn it
you would think if you were the sixth
largest [ __ ] city
in the united states that when i take a
non-stop flight
from [ __ ] los angeles
to philadelphia i could get a plane that
was a little newer than the one that i
flew on that i swear to god
will smith sat on that thing when he
went out to go test for the fresh prince
of bel-air
oh i'll tell you it was old
i took the red eye right
i go on there played for paid for a
first class ticket because i'm a fancy
man all right and i earned it too
god damn it
i spent the better part of two decades
in the back of the [ __ ] plane
okay and i can spot
i can spot a middle seater from a mile
away when i'm sitting in the terminal
going aw man that son of a [ __ ]
i saw this guy like classic
fat guy right
giant [ __ ] polo shirt like a poncho
hanging off his gigantic torso with the
cargo shorts on
legs out in the eczema
okay
neck pillow and i'm like that that's got
middle seat written all over it
okay and he's gonna wait to get on the
[ __ ] plane
you know what i mean like a like a
murder mystery
like a great whodunit
who's gonna sit next to me
you know maybe maybe somebody
maybe somebody isn't going to be on that
middle seat and then you hear the
stewardess go we have a very full flight
please don't put all your [ __ ] the
overhead compartments everybody does
that everywhere just try to have it be
your wheelies some douche stuff in a
jacket like two feet from her
announcement just [ __ ] stuffing it in
there right and by the way this old ass
plane the [ __ ] intercom is on full
blast
i do the impression but i'm gonna save
your ears just in case you have the
headphones on
full [ __ ] blast
so anyway i get on the [ __ ] plane
it's like those first class seats from
like you know the 90s
the [ __ ] leather chair all wrinkled
that's lost its luster from all those
years a salesman [ __ ] you know
getting all boozed up and passing out in
it
you can't recline it i had to sleep
sitting up
paid for a first class ticket i don't
give a [ __ ] what you fly down everything
has the sleeper seats if you're up front
right
i have a big [ __ ] head i got a
goddamn snow globe sitting on my
shoulders i got an actual globe
who's kidding it's a moon
that [ __ ] goes around the planet of
jupiter right
i'm [ __ ] trying to sleep all night my
head keeps going forward [ __ ] waking
me up and then i gotta go back
you know
and you know i like the design of an
airplane how it works because it's
designed to fly it's not designed to
sleep on like anything you try to do in
one of those old-school seats or if
you're a poor bastard in the back of the
plane i'ma tell you right now i root for
all you guys
you know i'm rooting for that fat guy
with the leg eczema to [ __ ]
you know lose the weight i root for
people i make fun of people but i root
for
okay and that's how i justify what a
[ __ ] i am so anyway
it's like okay
this isn't comfortable
what if what if i lean my head on the
side of the fuselage and it's just far
enough
that it makes the other side of your
neck stretch out right you're like [ __ ]
you can't do that all right what if i
open the tv tray up right
tv tray the [ __ ]
the food tray
what if i you know when i put my head
down on my desk you know like back in
the day when the teacher had enough of
you
we're gonna have silence and she'd shut
the lights off in the room everybody put
their heads down in the desk then you
put your head down you'd be peeking at
your friend
he'd be making fart noises with his
[ __ ] hands remember
right
[ __ ] laughing your ass off next thing
you know you're staying after school to
clap the erasers
um
you're going to put your [ __ ] head
down on that it's just close enough to
your body where you feel like you're
going to fold your spine in half
and at just some point you just look
over the person sitting next to you who
has a neck pillow
that you've made fun of
the entire time you've ever seen him and
you're like you know what
that was the move
i wish i bought a neck pillow i only
bought one my entire time
my entire time flying out in the back
i only bought one neck pillow
it was blue
to bring out my eyes
and uh i only used it a couple of times
and i it just took up too much space
you know
because i don't give a [ __ ] how long i'm
going out on the road i never check a
bag
unless i go on vacation
with my wife
and then she's always like we're gonna
go swimming
you should bring your flip-flops have a
bathing suit bring your goggles okay
cool but what if we want to go out to
dinner one night
you know maybe one night we'll get a
sitter you and i could go someplace
really nice try and reconnect maybe you
should bring like a sport coat or
something
all right okay i'll do that now what if
on one of these days what if it rains
what if it rains you should have a
raincoat
and just you know
i can't fit all this in a little bag
well you should bring your bigger bag
just bring your bigger bag i'm telling
you just do it you'll have all kinds of
options
everything's going to be great just
trust me trust me on this one because
i'm checking a bag too so you're going
to be waiting there anyway
why you know what how much long is it
going to take just to wait for your bag
and i always go okay and then you know
what happens i go on vacation and every
day i wear the same pair of sweatpants
and t-shirt every [ __ ] day
you know and half the [ __ ] stays [ __ ]
sitting in the bag and i think to myself
you know what
i could have just brought the smaller
one but she made a great point that i
would have been waiting for her anyway
so who gives a [ __ ] right
i'll tell you who gives a [ __ ] the guy
who had to pick the bag up and put it on
the plane
blows out his [ __ ]
lower back um
so whenever i travel alone
whenever i travel alone there's no
[ __ ] way
i'm prolonging
this experience here at the goddamn
airport i want to get the [ __ ] out of
here
so um
anyway
i get on the [ __ ] plane and i i think
i actually slept for most of it still
but like why doesn't philly like they've
always had just [ __ ] flights
i remember before american took over
that i guess non-stop
u.s air had it
and jesus christ they had the even
shittier planes
you know what i mean so i don't know
next time i'll just fly into [ __ ] i
don't know where
dc or newark
but newark was like underwater
like hey man uh the vibe here in new
york city
the vibe in new york city has really
[ __ ] changed it's gone back like
after this pandemic you can just you
know a lot more trash a lot more [ __ ]
homeless people and [ __ ] i guess the
liberals had to change some sort of gun
law
looking out for people's human rights
you know which is never a bad thing but
i guess it makes it easy to walk around
with the guns so violence is up
i was told to keep my head on a swivel
now i don't like any of that that that
allegedly happening happening in new
york but what i'm hoping it's going to
do is make the crowds a little bit
better than they were when i was here
two years ago
doing the pete davidson movie
you know when it was at the literally
the height
of the phony woke white person
i am woke because i bestowed that title
upon myself
i
said that i am woke therefore i am woke
so
anyway i was trying to say i had like
one of the best experiences watching a
football game
um
i was working with joe bartnick who by
the way
is absolutely [ __ ] murdering he was
killing so hard that when we went down
to the sportsbook the next day to watch
college football people were coming up
to him i was two people away from they
didn't even see me
oh billy [ __ ] ego face was sitting
there going i guess it's over
i guess uh i guess i don't have the
[ __ ] the lusters off the [ __ ]
orange apple here
um
coming up to them right so we go down to
the sports book
i had a little cigar my first one in a
couple two three weeks
and uh
i had a smoothie mr almond smoothie i
highly recommend at the hard rock cafe
i had hit the gym
you know both [ __ ] days
having a good time oh billy flat bellies
coming in full effect we go down to the
sportsbook
and uh i was like i was gonna bet
wisconsin
because penn state's had a rough time
the last couple years
and bartnik's like come on man we're
doing a gig out in penn state coming up
he goes uh what are you you know that's
bad karma i was like you know what
you're right i'll take penn state and
then he liked the georgia bulldogs and i
was like you know it's the first week
what the [ __ ] do i know i'll take the
georgia bulldogs too then i go look at
this
the late game lsu
is playing ucla i'll bet lsu so every
one of them i bet the spread i don't
like combining games
you know what i mean
that's like you know
the plane crashes and everybody [ __ ]
crawls out we all we all have to survive
you know you go solo that's what the
[ __ ] you do you got a better chance you
know i don't want to [ __ ] be hanging
with this sleep apnea guy
um
so i bet penn state
which is one of the great college games
i've seen classic big 10 match up
zero zero at the half
okay
not you know not true sports fans are
shutting it off because all they all you
know when you're not a fan of a sport
what you want to see is offense
that's your big [ __ ] thing all right
you want to see scoring
it's like you know when an american
watches soccer
what is our big complaint dude nothing's
happening
meaning the ball isn't going into the
[ __ ] net that doesn't mean nothing's
happening you just don't have an ability
to watch the game
at a higher level i guess of
understanding it
um
so let me see here i want to make sure i
got the penn state roster here so i give
a shout out to some of the players um
[Music]
who was that kid who got kicked out of
the [ __ ] game
for that [ __ ] targeting
he was such a [ __ ] target that the
refs didn't even [ __ ] call it and
then the quarterback sitting there
complaining he hit him with his shoulder
and the helmet at the same time i
understand
that it's it's it's a uh
i don't know i forget the names number
five that wide receiver they couldn't
cover him number 13
and i think a guy number 41 on the
defense
had a nice big hit
and uh just a
right down to the end
right down to the end uh uh an
incredible game
and uh penn state with some huge stops
turnovers and all of that type of stuff
and i got money on the game and i was
flipping out what ellis burks
thought he played for the or is it
brooks
um ellis burks play for the red sox i
don't know
great game you know i just put 100 bucks
on 100 to win like 95 right and then the
georgia bulldogs right another 100 to
make 95. i hit that one too and then lsu
uh you know just couldn't make it happen
i love all these [ __ ] [ __ ] so in
the end you know then i lost that
hundred bucks i was up like 95 bucks or
whatever the [ __ ] it was
but i was just sitting there smoking a
stick
you know smoking a cigar inside is just
unbelievable and i always think of this
highlight that i saw a long time ago
of this um
world series game i want to say was the
mets
not the one in 69 when they won i think
they went to the world series again in
the early 70s and they lost
but it was a game at shea stadium
it was a world series of course it was
during the day because that's
how they did it back then
it's probably over in two and a half
hours two hours and 20 minutes
like baseball games were back in the day
and they cut to the crowd at one point
and there's a guy in the crowd
with a hat on not a hipster wearing a
hat because that's was part of his
generation
and he was smoking a cigar
those women around him nobody was
bitching at him
i was just like can you [ __ ] imagine
going to the world series it's on during
the day
it's gonna be over in two and a half
hours and you could sit in the stands
smoking a cigar
oh my god
[ __ ] amazing so the closest i can get
is go to a sports book i love that you
can smoke inside
because like hey man you guys are
gamblers right you like living on the
edge breathe in this secondhand smoke
so uh anyway we watched um
penn state i watched alabama jesus
christ absolutely destroy
miami i mean that game just got boring
really quickly and then we went down for
the show and georgia and lsu are both
playing at the same time and i love all
these [ __ ] [ __ ] getting all over
ed o'giron just being like oh was that
one year just a flu because he had joe
burrows is he the gene chizik
you know
coached at auburn and won a national
championship with cam newton it's just
like since when does a coach not need
the players
they did that to bill belichick last
year when tom brady won oh does bill
belichick not know what he's doing
i mean gene chizik was the guy that
actually began the turnaround of the
iowa state football program
i read this whole article about the guy
he you know
like auburn came and seeked him out
then he went down and applied being all
right i'll do it because it's good to
get my face down there they're not going
to hire me and then they [ __ ] hired
him and at the end of the day cam newton
and nut
he still has to come with the game plan
which he did he was also a defensive
coordinator which i also think helped
and the guy won a national championship
how the [ __ ] do you win a national
championship as a coach and [ __ ]
[ __ ] fans are still going i think it
was just a fluke
he just got lucky
he just needed one [ __ ] player that's
all
what's really going on what are you
really upset with in your [ __ ] life i
love it oh geron and i love what he said
you know that ucla [ __ ] players
screaming at him and [ __ ]
and he goes bring your ass on down here
with your [ __ ] blue shirt
[ __ ] hilarious
which it was and of course people like
aren't coaches supposed to set an
example
you know i was like what about that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
screaming at him he obviously wanted to
talk [ __ ]
he obviously wanted to [ __ ] stir it
up a little bit
he wanted to take the bulb by the horns
take on the bull you get the horns
that's what the [ __ ] happened i love
that he said it was [ __ ] hilarious
you know that goes back to that bit i
used to do
about uh the malice in the palace
when that [ __ ] [ __ ] threw that
drink
on meta world peace right
and then he did it's just like you
explained to me any other place in the
world whether a guy his size would take
a full drink and throw it
in a guy uh
world peace's size
he wouldn't and then he's at a [ __ ]
game
and then he does that [ __ ] and then as
as a [ __ ] man this guy's supposed to
let somebody throw a drink in his face
and not do anything about it
you know and i remember when that [ __ ]
came out all of those that was the whole
source of the bit all of the [ __ ]
sportscasters going like there is no
reason for you to ever go to the stands
there absolutely is a reason
and i think because he did that
that made a lot of fans maybe get their
[ __ ] behavior in check a little bit
every once in a while you have to go
into the stands boston bruins
the indiana pacers and they do all the
athletes that come into the league for
the next five to seven years of favor
because everybody remembers that like
you know there is a line
and these world class athletes are going
to come up into the stands
grab the wrong person and beat the [ __ ]
um all right let's do a little uh let's
do a little
advertising here
wait i can't i got to talk about a few
other things
um
what was i gonna say i've been watching
some of the us open i tweeted
joking around like i always forget that
i love tennis because
you know there's only so many hours in
the day
and all you have to do is just
tune in to a major and just sit down and
watch a tennis match to realize the
absolute [ __ ] war that a game of
tennis is in the amount of like
you know back and forth of momentum the
psychology of it i mean it's just
incredible i watched uh that carlos
alvarez or is it alvarazz i don't know
it's easy not easy
um defeat
that
stefano uh
is that how you say it the bathroom
break guy
i guess he took a bath for a seven
minute bathroom break and let the other
guy cool down
in his previous match and came out and
kicked his ass which was like within the
rules
so afterwards the press was giving him
[ __ ] and he goes well
you know tell me what the rule is
well you know it's sort of an unwritten
rule that maybe you don't take a [ __ ]
seven minute piss
tell me where it says that you know i i
would like you to look back uh djokovic
you know or what about that uh seven
year yeah that was a three minute piss
okay well you know
i have more fluids my uh big you know
big greek dick it takes you know longer
time to come out the tunnel
um so they were all giving him [ __ ]
about that
but carlos alvarez
was on s is the uh
first time since the early 70s like a
guy ranked as low as him defeats a three
seed and then i also watched this woman
uh
is it layla elie y l-a-h fernandez
defeat a three-seed
and uh
i don't know you just sit down you start
watching and you get just [ __ ] get
into it
and uh
i'll tell you a five set men's
match takes like four hours
four [ __ ] hours of those guys out
there i mean i don't i don't know how i
now understand why most of them retire
by the time they're 30. forget about
your your the obvious your body just
given out after a while just like dude i
can't [ __ ] do with this with the shin
splints and [ __ ]
uh i just can't even imagine the the
mental
like you're getting the ball every
possession it's either coming at you or
you're serving it
you know you lose a couple of games
don't quit on the set just play every
[ __ ] point play every [ __ ] point
for four hours
it's incredible it's an incredible game
and uh i wish i had more time to watch
it
all right oh okay we're gonna do a
little advertising here look who it is
everybody oh zip
you know according to forbes gyms nail
salons hotels mom and pop stores
and more
uh are set to go on an epic hiring spree
in the coming months to meet the pent-up
demand for all these services
okay talk about any business that you
were especially excited to return to or
that you have already returned to uh
what am i excited uh
what am i excited about
oh geez i'm dropping the ball uh bars
bars [ __ ] uh cigar bars
uh
i don't know i don't go shop movie
theater there you go they gave me the
answer i could love to go to a movie
theater
i would love to go to a movie theater i
like that the gyms at the hotels are
open again
so i can go down there and be billy
balliptical
and knock out my calories um all of
these businesses reopening means that
millions of jobs will need to be filled
so where do these businesses turn to to
fill these rolls fast oh zip
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
when you post a job on zip
i get it
they send your job to over 100 job sites
giving you access to their networks of
millions
of job seekers you can easily review
recommend
review recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
which encourages them to apply faster
zip
technology is so effective that four to
five employees who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day and right now you can try zip
for free at this exclusive website
ziprecruiter.com
that's ziprecruiter.com
just go to ziprecruiter.com
zip
the smartest way to hire
all right oh look who it is everybody my
bookie how the [ __ ] you doing huh
you look like easy money
who doesn't
you who doesn't like easy money
oh you like easy money i'll say why
would you say you look like easy money
that sounds like they're gonna take
take your money okay you like easy money
who doesn't like easy money
head to mybookie.ag bet the nfl lock of
the season and when any team scores
between the dallas cowboys and the tampa
bucks you
win when any team scores between the
dallas cowboys and the tampa bucks you
win i don't know what that means the
best bet you can make is one you can't
lose
and in the case in case you didn't know
a game hasn't ended 0-0 since world war
ii so this is sure bet okay
lock of the season
when any team scores between the dallas
cowboys and the tampa bay bucks you win
so all you need is some of your score
points and you win they're giving you
they're giving you
a winner
uh it really is that simple join my
bookie now bet the luck of the season
and when the first point is scored in
the season opener on thursday night you
automatically win cash well it's
definitely
there's going to be some scoring because
uh
you know the way they've opened up the
offense slowly but surely over the last
[ __ ] 20 years
um
it's almost impossible not to score uh
my bookie is playing host to several
exclusive contests including their 100
super contest
and it only cost ten dollars to enter
there's big money on the line this
season so don't wait to get into the
game join now head to mybookie.ag
today and go
then use our promo code bur and
instantly receive double your first
deposit that's double your funds to
double your winnings again that's promo
code bird to receive double your first
deposit and get started with my bookie
today bet anything anytime anywhere with
my bookie all right back to the podcast
push up challenge
hey billy whirlybird
it seems that we have a bit in common
we're both pilots nice we both yell at
inanimate objects that [ __ ] with us
um i love that they're [ __ ] with us
that makes them animate at that point
right
or alive on some level and we are both
measuring our fitness at least in part
based upon our ability to match doing as
many push-ups as our age i haven't done
that a few years because of my shoulders
but my shoulder has felt better than it
ever has
he said on my way to 50 i was skeptical
that i'd be able to do it but when the
time came i did indeed meet the
challenge so when he turned 50 he did 50
push-ups now at 61. i'm happy to say
that i haven't failed failed the age
slash push-up challenge yet that's
amazing man 61 push-ups is no joke
that is no joke and uh i think it's a
great thing to do you should also do it
with squats
are hugely important because uh
you know you don't want to be that guy
that ends up you know always cold and
has a blanket on his over his legs you
know when you get that level old
the [ __ ] grim reaper's just standing
behind you every time you lean forward
to grab the remote
if you [ __ ] do a header out of your
chair that's gonna be it for you right
so i would throw some squats in there
too
but that's really inspiring um
i'm excited because uh
my masseuse the genius that she is gave
me these these shoulder exercises that
are just the body weight
of my uh
my arms and i do them every single day
and then i got one of those little
exercise balls there like almost like a
foam roller but it's a hard ball keep it
clean ladies
um why would you want a hard ball you
want a hard dick stupid anyway
and you just put it between
you know your shoulder or your back and
the wall
and you can control the direction and
the pressure
and i basically roll out my shoulders
and my back
you know
almost every single day and then i do
that so as stretch
you know the the up dog or the cobra
and i'm trying to get it to the point
where i i can actually have hips on the
floor and go straight up like 90 degrees
i've just decided i'm going to work on
that because
um
i think that's one of the most neglected
stretches out there if your psoas which
is the muscle in the front of you
that connects the trunk of your body in
the front
to your your lower body
and it's in the front and then wraps
around your back
i don't know i think back towards your
spine or something like that and if that
thing gets tight which happens if you
sit down a lot like me flying you know
um all around the country
and that gets tight
you know it starts to pull your your
torso forward so your lower back has to
engage
so a lot of time and then your lower
back starts hurting so i find a lot of
times when i think i have lower back
pain there's something wrong with my
back i need to stretch out my back i
actually need to stretch out my sewer so
i'm really trying to work on that you
know just to live a healthier lifestyle
okay um all right going blind drunk hey
billy [ __ ] tits
um yeah i was sitting there going like
is that actually a true thing going
blind drunk and i couldn't find
the truth of it but it was as luck would
have it i watched this episode of the
untouchables with robert blake the
original one
where um
a
very very very young
robert
redford um
played the bad guy in that one and he
was taking wood alcohol
and they were selling it on college
campuses and two kids lost their sight
and one
woman
uh died
and i guess what it is is it attacks
it's not the alcohol it's what there's
some chemical that it gives off not the
alcohol it's another chemical that's in
wood alcohol that attacks the optic
nerve
and it could do damage where you're
blind for a moment or you could actually
if you drank enough of it you'd go blind
for the rest of your life
and um
they used to have this thing called
there was another one called uh
it was called uh jake leg
and there was another one that would
actually attack like your central or
something in your brain or something
like that
and you'd get up and you would do like
this crazy walk
because like you know it damaged your
nerves and you have to like lift your
whole leg to make your foot come up
and uh
i don't know so i learned that since
then but let's see what this person says
all right long time listener was
checking out the uh monday morning
podcast for august 30th and you were
trying to fact check yourself regarding
blindness due to impure alcohol but
couldn't get a source
and said you must have been wrong guess
what genius you were actually right
uh if you do not properly ferment and
distill alcohol there could be some
nasty byproducts include methanol yeah
that's it the active ingredient in
alcohol is
ethanol
which differs from methanol in that it
has one additional carbon and a couple
extra hydrogen methanol ingestion is
pretty dangerous an enzyme in your body
called alcohol dehydrogenase
metabolizes it into
formic acid and formaldehyde which are
highly toxic and can cause not only
temporary but permanent blindness crazy
right
uh what's even crazier is that the
treatment for methanol ingestion can
include giving the individual more
ethanol aka get them drunker this is
because ethanol and methanol are
agonists
i guess opposites of a receptor called a
alcohol
dehydrogenase come on dude you know who
i am what are you doing with all these
big words without going into a science
lesson you should have done it
i mean i would have retained it but my
listeners would it's pretty basic more
ethanol results and less methanol being
metabolized so you don't go blind from
your bathtub moonshine i've attached a
source in case you think i'm
bullshitting thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
p.s
come to albuquerque you redhead
uh i would love to
i would love to go to albuquerque
um every time i go to albuquerque i
think all the wonderful experiences i
had
playing a very very super small role in
one of my favorite tv shows of all time
breaking bad
um
i still remember that cool airport with
that giant snake thing that they have
when you go down the hill
uh i also remember standing on set
watching weather from like 30 miles away
approaching just seeing a rainstorm
coming it was [ __ ] amazing um
absolutely gorgeous
gorgeous part of the country
um new mexico is
and uh you know a nice amount of people
out there i'm a big big fan of new
mexico and also not to mention that a
bunch of [ __ ] uh
mma legends have come out of there
um so yeah there's a lot of things to
like about
new mexico all right independent woman
rant
billy boy saw this on reddit and thought
you enjoyed girl wants to be
an old-school woman
no wait a minute she wants to be an
old-school woman i know she's this seems
like she's gonna trick you
all right
okay let's see what she says here i'm
supposed to watch this 37 seconds there
we go
and of course this sound doesn't work
the sound does not work come on
what am i doing wrong
see this is why i even if i
okay hang on a second let me tell you
something
from the 60s really messed up my life
goals
you want to stay at home
and clean the house
take care of the kids
you know have dinner ready for your
husbands when they got home from work
she's putting on makeup that is all i
want to do
but no you thought everyone wanted to be
independent i don't
i don't want to be independent
well here i am
[Music]
she must have had a paper due that day
um
yeah i've heard that argument before
i think you should be allowed to
you shouldn't women you shouldn't treat
another woman as a sellout
if she just wants to stay home and take
care of kids and also that's one less
woman you have to compete for in the job
world so you know she's doing your favor
she's taking herself out of the game
um i do have to tell you that woman had
a bit of a temper on her that made me a
little nervous i gotta be like uh yeah
that would not be a that'd not be a good
person for me to be with my [ __ ]
temper
um
so
anyway and as much as guys
i don't know how do guys complain about
that i mean it's kind of cool to have a
wife that has a job and brings home a
little bit of bacon there
um
anyway wife never wants sex
hey billy clown face me and my lady have
been married for almost five and a half
years and been together over six years
i'm 38 and my wife is 32 before we got
married everything was perfect and at
that time i thought i had found the girl
i wanted to grow old with unfortunately
everything went out the window the
weekend we got mad the weekend
we didn't have sex before we got married
so i expected her to be ready to go or
show some excitement about us having sex
for the first time on our wedding night
we got to the hotel and she just acted
like we walked into a grocery store or
something she thought it was weird i was
trying to initiate anything sexual with
her oh my god
we eventually did have sex but it seemed
like more of a
i guess we can have sex now vibe the
weird thing is she actually bragged
about her sex life with her ex that
night too
what
what did she say you know this last guy
i used to really [ __ ] him all the time
oh man we had a great time
so then she got with you so she wasn't a
virgin so she was banging before she
stopped banging when she met you
and now you're on your wedding night and
she's acting like she's at the grocery
store okay since then it's been constant
rejection i could probably count on one
hand no more than two the number of
times she has initiated sex in our
marriage and she actually barely
initiates any kind of physical affection
so i wonder if she actually did have a
great sex life with this other person
um there was no honeymoon phase or
anything sex maybe three times a month
as newlyweds anytime i brought up the
lack of anything in our marriage it
always turned into a fight where i was
told you make me feel like a failure as
a wife we are married now
we are past all that that stuff is for
teenagers and i didn't get married to
have sex
okay something's going on with her did
something happen to her when she was
younger
is she gay
you know that could be a thing maybe
she's trying to make her parents happy
and
he's living you know
a life she shouldn't be living
does she not do you have halitosis and
she doesn't know how to tell you
uh the sad thing is over time she has
led a few things
about her past relationship that lasted
six years or so come out and she made it
seem like she had a long sex life with
this other guy
she had the honeymoon phase with him and
pretty much got all the sex she wanted
before we got married and now just wants
a roommate that will pay the bills
she will let me have sex with her once a
week but definitely nothing more to her
once a week is enough but i want
but if i want anything more than that
she claims i'm just i just demand sex
from her all the time and i'm needy
because i want a wife instead of a
roommate as a christian i don't want to
get a divorce
well as a christian catholic church was
also
falls under the umbrella of christianity
and look what they did
okay
um
we also had crusades as christians and
did horrible things to muslim people and
all that stuff so i mean
listen if you're not happy get out of it
he said but i also don't want to be
45 in a marriage that lacks any kind of
intimacy either at what point do you
think it's okay to bail and find someone
else i'll tell you this right now your
heart your soul
and everything that makes you
an alive person has already left this
marriage
i'm sorry that this happened to you i
know it's going to be painful just get
the [ __ ] out and i'm telling you this
time next year
you know
you're gonna be looking back going what
in the [ __ ] was that thank god i got out
of it and you're gonna be happy as hell
even if you're single
you're gonna meet a woman that likes to
have sex with you and it's gonna make
you feel good nobody should go through
that
that constant rejection and dealing with
that okay
this is just like
you know there's a guy out there for
your wife but you ain't it so
you know
you're making her feel a certain way
she's making you feel a certain way it's
not going to get better so
you know and you don't want to be old
thinking like i should have just got out
of it why the [ __ ] did i do that and
another thing too how the [ __ ] you gonna
have a kid if you're having sex once a
[ __ ] week
you know if you want to have a kid i
don't know if you want to have a [ __ ]
kid but you know you got to bang away
that week when she's ovulating all right
shark or lion
hey there billy the freckled butthole
burr
i have a question for you i listened to
your segment on sharks the other day and
wants to know if you had if you had to
choose gun to your head
being eaten by a shark in the open ocean
oh my god or be eaten by a lion in the
bush
ah dude that's the easiest question ever
he goes i know either way you're going
to
you're going to get eaten however my
thing my thinking is that it would be
better to get mauled by a lion than a
shark at least with the lion you don't
have to you don't have to fight drowning
as well i would like to know what your
opinion is on this very important topic
love to stand up in the podcast well
thank you uh keep well and go [ __ ]
yourself a south african fan shout out
to south africa
um
oh a lion all day long
and i am basing that on
you know
siegfried and roy i think that was a
tiger whatever a big cat dude that thing
grabbed him and within two seconds he
went limp
and then that was it i'm not saying i'm
happy that happened it was absolutely
horrific whatever but like you know
you're playing with lions and tigers you
know eventually something's gonna happen
right
so
he just went [ __ ] limp
choked out immediately what i love about
cats
big
[ __ ] cats is they put they it's over
they grab you you're like
and then they just clamp down and they
choke you out you ask any mma person
they would rather get [ __ ] choked out
than knocked out they don't want to do
you know it's just you know you go to
sleep
then you woke up oh i lost oh okay
i don't have any cognitive damage you
just go to sleep and you would wake up
wherever the [ __ ] you go or you're just
dead you know if that's what happens
like a squirrel you're just dead
a shark is gonna bite you first you
can't [ __ ] see it
it's gonna take a bite out of you to see
what you taste like
to see if there's any sort of threat
there oh my god then it's gonna pull you
under the water as you're fighting to
breathe and stay above the water not
even close and the [ __ ] loneliness
of being out in the middle of the
[ __ ] ocean you oh my god you can just
you can take that uh
that shark thing any [ __ ] day you
know
i absolutely
i would almost if you said would you
rather get killed by a lion
or just bitten by a shark
but you're gonna live
i know survival i would have to choose
the shark but just going okay it's gonna
happen and they drop you in the water
just waiting
[ __ ] that
you know
that's why i can't stand bears as much
as i love a bear the fact that they just
don't grab their prey by the neck and
put them out of their misery they just
[ __ ] hold them down
like a big dummy you know and just start
biting [ __ ]
you know i don't it's terrible i don't
want to get mauled
uh i want to get choked out that was an
easy one
absolutely [ __ ] easy
um all right do i deserve to marry a
rich doctor
well don't marry the person because
he or she is a rich doctor marry them
because they treat you right then the
benefits you married is smartie that's
bringing on the money there all right
hello mr bill best comedian in the world
burr look at that i get a compliment i'm
a 25 year old guy from morocco
oh my god casablanca
uh who's lost
and uh don't know what to do and need
your take on this i met this young lady
six months ago and we're in love she's
an amazing nice and motivated young lady
she's on her fourth year in medical
school dude you hit the [ __ ] lottery
amazingly nice she's motivated
she's super smart
well i work in an office job that
doesn't pay really well and has no
future and she's [ __ ] cool she likes
you for who you are then
the thing is i've been panicking lately
because i feel that i haven't found a
path or what i want to do and maybe i
don't deserve her oh jesus christ
she's from a rich family full of doctors
also and she's seen and experienced a
lot of things while i never did [ __ ] and
struggle to have a good
dinner out during the weekend we're
planning to spend our lives together and
she loves me for who i am yes she does
dude don't [ __ ] this up
okay if anything go to her and tell her
how much you admire her that she found
her path
and that you know and tell her how you
feel
i just tell her how you feel
how great she is and you almost feel
like you don't deserve her and how you
want to find
your path because you want to contribute
to the relationship more do that don't
don't sabotage this
he goes but i don't know if i deserve
her and i don't know what i can do to
find a good career so i can make
a lot lot a living
in the same level first of all don't
compete with her
he said sorry for the long email help
this miserable guy who's happy for the
first time in life but he thinks he'll
mess it up yeah you got issues dude
you got [ __ ] issues where um
you're saying you're happy for the first
time in life so what what it is is
you've been miserable so long that
misery
is your comfort zone
even though you don't want to be
miserable you're comfortable you know i
know that because i used to be like that
you know i grew up in a very volatile
crazy
[ __ ] situation in world and all of
that type of stuff and i was like i'm
not [ __ ] doing that i'm going to be
around nice peaceful calm people and
what you do is you gravitate towards
what feels familiar subconsciously
without even knowing it and you're
surrounded yourself by a bunch of
lunatics and you fit right in because
you're a lunatic
so here's the thing dude you found
happiness
all right
just allow yourself to be uncomfortable
with that
and gradually get comfortable with it
and what you need to do is communicate
with her okay you obviously are head
over heels with this woman you
absolutely love her you should marry her
and use her as an example of the kind of
person that you want to be happy
motivated
and don't put pressure on yourself
to make as much money as she's gonna be
making it's like the only person who's
she's not doing that to you so why do
that to yourself
all right
and uh as far as like finding out what
you're supposed to do in life just
follow your heart i know that's [ __ ]
cliche but like
like
think about what you like what you're
interested in try a bunch of different
things
and if there's something that you know
you find something that you would just
do anyway
if you can turn that into a job
you you never feel like you're working
so uh don't [ __ ] this up dude that's
really gonna
make me sad if you do that all right you
deserve this person and you know why you
deserve this person because you've been
miserable your whole life
which means your family your parents
probably made you [ __ ] miserable you
deserve happiness but you don't feel you
deserve happiness because the people
that loved you made you [ __ ]
miserable so get into therapy which you
don't have money for maybe that maybe
you got like i don't know
nationwide healthcare over there in
morocco and you just
talk this [ __ ] out
either with the therapist and with the
woman that you're with don't [ __ ] this
up because it sounds like you got a
great one all right
so there you go all right that's the
podcast everybody
um
oh billy [ __ ] twinkle toes is gonna
go work out now
keep it going
uh i'm here in new york city
you know i'm going to be doing this 9 11
benefits so i'm going to be uh [ __ ]
out and about walking around hopefully
right
trying to uh you know burn off the
calories
maybe i'll go to a gym you know but then
they always want can i see your driver's
license it's like can you how about i
just give you my [ __ ] credit card
then you give them the driver's license
and then they're putting it in the
computer it's like what are you doing
you're not the government oh we don't do
anything with this no sir you don't do
anything with this
then it goes into the computer then
where does it go
you [ __ ]
so i think i'm just gonna uh
i don't know walk to the comedy clubs i
have no idea what i'm gonna do here but
i'm gonna stay away from the bagels and
the cream cheese i'm gonna stay away
from the pizza
i'm gonna stay away from all of that
[ __ ] because uh
i actually got a [ __ ] steak and
cheese
i got a great one i got a joe bartnik
suggested when we were on our way up to
uh
bethlehem pennsylvania
we went through uh the great city of
philadelphia
that for some reason does not get the
good planes when you fly to it
uh i took a picture was tony something
not tony o's what the [ __ ] was it tony
ells
what the hell was it
come on come on
tony luke's
tony lukes
a great
great goddamn cheesesteak i ate that
thing man i wasn't hungry for the rest
of the afternoon
into the evening i didn't i had two
shows last night in bethlehem which by
the way what an amazing city that is
just [ __ ] beautiful i mean
pennsylvania is so underrated how
beautiful state is all the trees and the
rivers and all that type of stuff
granted you pull in and there's a
[ __ ] steel mill about ready to fall
down i'm sure you know they think you
know it definitely looked like uh
you know i was joking with them that
they probably filmed a couple episodes
of the first 48 there but you can see
the bones the bones they got a good
structure there it is a beautiful town
so um
i've always loved those old
you know rust belt type of towns and
watching them all slowly coming back
first pittsburgh cleveland uh detroit
was even coming around i don't know
where they're at now the stupid pandemic
[ __ ]
but hopefully they're coming around too
uh buffalo is another one that i love
i love all of that [ __ ] um all right so
anyways that is the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves nfl uh football
kicks off this thursday
i guess is it it's tampa vs dallas tom
brady going for ring
number
eight
which would tie him with bill belichick
don't ever forget he has two as a
defensive coordinator when he was with
the g men
um all right that's it everybody go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll check in on you on
thursday
you